you're watching reason live streaming to
you from Los Angeles the following is a
live conversation between the host the
guests and the online audience if you'd
like to participate please leave your
question in the YouTube chat the views
expressed by guests and the audience
members in this discussion do not
necessarily reflect those of reason and
now your host Zach why some more hello
thank you for joining us for our fourth
of five days of live streaming here on
reason today we're going to be talking
with Christian O'Brien he is one of the
co-creators and co-writers of the
YouTube channel 1791 formerly known as
1791 ell and we're gonna be talking
about the future of the right which I
believe he is a part of we'll talk about
that a little bit how he self defines
but from my perspective they are a
conservative slash libertarian channel
that has just amazing graphics work
produced by Lex Vienna I believe is how
you pronounce it Lex is a an artist I
gotta say the stuff is really remarkable
if you haven't seen it you should head
over and check it out the the YouTube
channel is youtube.com forward slash
1791 l and we'll be talking with him
like I said about the future of the
right D platforming just the the whole
notion of talking about politics on
YouTube and and kind of venturing
outside of what's the approved opinion
and how that presents some difficulties
and they just got a phone call with
patreon support so we'll hear a little
bit about that later and also welcome to
all the 1791 fans who are watching I
know
Christian
and 1791 sent out some tweets so thanks
for watching and I hope you enjoy the
conversation what we're trying to do
here that this is an experimental form
for us here at reason we're just trying
it all this week to see how it goes to
see what the reactions are like if
there's an audience for it and producer
coming sneaking in a little late that's
the beauty of live also things anything
can happen and we before I bring
Christian in want to say that tomorrow
we'll have our last stream with Nick
Gillespie reasons own Nick Gillespie and
we're also going to be bringing on
Michael Shermer the publisher of skeptic
magazine and they're gonna be revisiting
a topic that we touched earlier this
year post-modernism we made a video kind
of replying to the myriad critiques of
post-modernism that are floating around
there on the Internet's now so Michael
Shermer and Nick will be talking about
that I'll be here just to kind of drive
the steer the ship and throw in some
clips and questions from all of you and
so if you have any questions for either
Nick or Michael you can go ahead and
email those to us now questions at
reason.com and now let's get to last
thing I should mention is if you want
notifications when these things go live
or when any of our documentaries or
interviews go live just be sure to
subscribe and press the little
notification bell and now we'll get into
our interview with Christian and I want
to start this with a clip from one of
their videos called information wars and
I think this will give you a sense of
their style where they're coming from
and hopefully launch our discussion on
the topic of free speech so hold tight
we'll be right back with Christian after
this clip many rush to eject from their
mouths private companies can do whatever
they want
this happens to be a tow
non Observation free speech isn't what's
being violated by their paternalistic
censorship true but effective speech is
because in the 21st century they've
effectively monopolized where effective
speech can exist proven by their joint
action here unlike a brand of beer or
deodorant you don't have the luxury of
10 or 15 competing options for video
streaming the only real player in the
game truly is YouTube jones has and will
retain his own platform but accessing
new audiences and maintaining his
current level of support becomes a much
more daunting hurdle which is what makes
this precedent so alarming of course
none of this is to say that Jones is the
kind of speech we'd like to see but that
anyone concerned with freedom of
information should have more trust in
the public to determine for themselves
the quality of someone's opinions than a
place their trust and transparently
ideological code monkeys all right Thank
You Christian for joining us hi there
that was a those a nice expand that was
a nice introduction you have a very good
job of that it's nice to speak with you
again yeah great great to have you on
and the the argument that you're making
in that first clip is not that Alex
Jones is somebody who any of us is
particularly interested in boosah beyond
just a carnival type sideshow but that
in this Wild West fractured media
environment where there's a kind of
maximal freedom you're going to have
characters like that pop up and it's
kind of a byproduct of that environment
and I guess the counter to that would be
I I spoke with a couple weeks ago Adam
Conover of Adam ruins everything and he
was kind of making the argument that
well these platforms do have a
responsibility when someone like Alex
Jones is rising to the top that there's
something about the very nature of the
platforms and the way the algorithms are
directing people to them that is causing
this and you know they've got to take
responsibility
step forward so could you just
articulate your side of that argument a
little bit more I would say that like
III agree with the the idea that to some
extent or another companies have an
obligation to you know respond to I'm
kind of two minds in this regard by
which on one hand I think you know
companies companies or you know they
they're they're not detached from the
obligations of other institutions like
the government and maybe you have sort
of social obligations but if you have a
maximal belief in freedom you have to
have a good that to some degree a faith
that in that domain in that battleground
of ideas the right ideas will prevail
and I think that you have to play some
sort of limits on you know the power of
these institutions to you know to
paternal eyes what the right way of
thinking is and if you accept that as a
premise then you know you're going to
it's going to continually expand and I
worried that you have this sort of this
sort of creeping creeping restriction
ISM on acceptable thought and the claim
that like you know okay Alex Jones is
rising to the top in terms of like what
I mean who's it's important not to
conflate interests and Alex Jones as you
know a like entertainer as somebody who
is like comical and is obviously playing
to watch that's why he's become one of
the most like large memes in recent
memory with the fact with how many
people are actually convicted of his
ideas and to the extent that Alex Jones
has penetrated the mainstream I don't
think that's the case I don't think
really really have a case there and
there's no way of making like you know
an objective differentiation between how
many people are watching him just a
spectacle and humorist even as opposed
to how many people are actually you know
info warriors and who I think we're much
smaller minority but there's still the
fact that people are interested in as it
mean was going to pump his numbers up
right
and it might inflate the extent to which
you think that he's a a social ill or
social risk and you know I think that
there are more bad things that will come
of that assumption that
deniz have because I mean you again it's
the same organ that people make against
you know handing the government more
power which is that you don't know who's
going to you don't understand the basis
on which people are gonna make their
decisions you don't know how many people
are morally corrupt the same thing
applies to effective monopolies like
social media or determining you know on
arbitrary base tizzle behind closed
doors we're in some sense even less
transparent than government if that's
even possible who is allowed to express
their opinion and like maybe my flaws
that I have more faith in the public's
ability to parse good ideas from bad
ideas and I think that we generally are
more able to and I think that if
anything the Internet has been in
antidote to social pathogens like that
was Alex Jones I mean somebody like Ben
Shapiro is undoubtedly more popular than
how much Jones who has spoken of in open
quarters unlike Alex Jones for the sole
reason and he's somebody who's who
repudiates Alex Jones had every given
opportunity and you know it's so I do
think that in the end good ideas prevail
over bad ones if given enough exposure I
do fundamentally believe my as a
fundamental operating premise that
sunlight is the best disinfectant and
you that clip opens with a little bit of
mockery of the people who are constantly
saying these are private companies they
can do whatever they want and I I
understand that that does get tiresome
but I the thing that I that I worry
about is if we don't constantly
reiterate that and then say you know
these are private companies but this is
bad
then I already see it on the
conservative side of the spectrum people
calling for regulation monopoly style
regulation or like neutrality Fairness
Doctrine style regulation on these
platforms is that's something that you
would want to see or are you calling for
more of sort of a market response and
and people just you know waking up to
this what's going on and I want a market
response and I think that honestly a
market response is on the horizon so I
think that the overzealous
calls for government intervention or
somewhat misguided but they are founded
in reasonable you know concerns as well
I think that you know the people who you
know say well you should you start your
own company or you should sort your own
financial infrastructure or being
totally unfeasible and like even like to
carry from their perspective they can
say okay well maybe if these companies
become too inflexible a market solution
will inevitably arise just as it does in
every other market why is the internet
distinct and that's all well and good
but it's another thing for an entire
financial structure to come in place of
something like patreon where it's like
okay YouTube is more concentrated and I
think that the internet operates in a
different domain than just products
because of the fact that they are it's
social media it's social by nature and
people want to congregate around one
thing one central mode of communication
so it's much harder to actually
facilitate a different option that's not
going to congeal around one thing and
once it congeals around run thing once
ideological actors creep into the
structure of it it might become
inflexibility and so that like that's my
fundamental concern and i think that we
have to it almost becomes something
that's more problematic than your
typical you know market problem i almost
like because the internet is such a new
thing it's such a new problem that I
maybe I'm being more too cynical and
maybe I'm not being sufficiently you
know open-minded but I worry that human
nature as it interacts with this this
fundamentally new phenomena it's not
going to be able to respond to it in the
way that it's been able to respond to
traditional businesses and I worried
that I worry that that traditional
market responses are not going to be the
same thing I because I have concerns
with regard to the the incoming Peterson
Reuben thing because of the fact that I
don't know how they're gonna detach
themselves from the existing financial
structure if banks are per se for
example telling sorry the incoming Rubin
Pearson thing could you clarify what
Pearson and Rubin have announced that
they're going to introduce a new
alternative to patreon okay we don't
know I don't know if you've seen that
but they have not did their light on the
details apparently it's been in the
works for a while and that's I look
forward to that but I also question
whether or not they're going to be able
to detach themselves from the existing
infrastructure which is very which has
been known to cancel payment options
they've done that with like Visa has
done this master card etc canceled
transactions to certain people they
fundamentally they banned other people
and I worry that they're going to be you
know isolated from that there's because
of the because of the nature of it
because of how intertangled
it is I question whether or not they're
actually going to be able to avoid that
and so you know again if these companies
are fundamentally so like you know
congealed I worry whether or not like
because I don't trust the government
with it either I don't think there's a I
don't know of a government solution to
this problem but I do know and that
traditional market solutions are going
to have to be pretty radical to have to
confront it but I think that those
solutions are only going I mean I hate
to put it this way but it it's kind of
like it needs to get worse before it
gets better because for there to be a
real market demand for those
alternatives bad stuff you know when
when it's Alex Jones getting banned most
people don't care they think he's a loon
and rightly so when it's people that are
more on the bubble like sargon of akkad
who we'll talk about later
it's people start to get concerned and
then you know we'll see what happens
with this dave rubin jordan peterson
partnership i mean these guys already
have huge audiences it seems like that
is something that could be viable we'll
see how it works out
before we there I'm gonna introduce
another clip in a second but before we
do I want to just ask some of the
questions that have come in we solicited
questions early and people sent emails
and comments so I want to make sure to
get those in
I appreciate people sending questions
along early and some people were
actually in the chat last night asking
questions and I unfortunately they were
erased this morning I didn't know that
would happen so apologies but ask them
now
in the chat and we'll get to them one
person who emailed me is Thomas Webber
and he just yesterday number of
questions but one is I don't want to
Doc's them but who are these guys
college students graduates or just too
politically active guys so I would go
for the the fourth mo the foremost
option which are just too politically
inclined guys essentially you know just
two guys that are impassioned by their
opinions which I hope is reflected in
our videos and I mean that's
fundamentally how I hope people approach
it which is just fundamental which is
basically what we all are regardless of
what your credentials are you're just
somebody with an opinion and I think
that we should just be able to weigh
people's opinions on their merits rather
than any other kind of consideration you
know what I mean hmm yep so you want to
keep some of the mystery alive there
I'll keep booking the mystery alive yeah
I'll keep the details obscure yeah and
he also asks first and foremost what is
their inspiration and not in the
Petersons slash Dostoyevsky sense more
like why they have an interest in
politics so you try to make sure I don't
give him like a Peter Sony and
roundabout response to that I would say
like like my inspirations my fundamental
inspirations are in terms of like
personalities I wonder or in terms of of
ideas I mean I came of consciousness
during Ron Paul's candidacy so in terms
of like a background I I did you know
it's befitting that this Q&A would
happen on reason because I grew up on a
steady diet of reason in both senses of
the term and but it was it was Ron Paul
and fundamentally that's that kind of
made me really inclined to her politics
I guess from like a very beginning sense
I was always they had that sort of
inclination toward it and so I had been
talking with friends and others from
like
whole range of little effectives my
entire upbringing and it was it was it
was but the people who find
fundamentally informed me probably were
Ron Paul who introduced me to you know
the other thinkers within the you know
libertarian panorama like Hayek and and
you know and and Mises and I gained a
sympathy for Guardian ISM and a certain
sense and then that kind of a gateway to
Buckley who kind of grounded me a little
bit more in traditional conservatism and
in kind of I'm still kind of undergoing
that process of reconciling my believe
in freedom versus the necess the
necessity of of directing that freedom
of channeling that freedom in its proper
direction yeah how did libertarians lose
you to William F Buckley that's a little
settle exactly well just in the sense
that I it's it's it's hard to say but it
was mostly that I considered the
libertarian approach I was taking and I
assume that there's a District Court in
the number of libertarians watching this
who they're gonna hate me for this but I
I begun to see it as kind of like
reductionist kind of overly reductionist
to a certain core of moral principles
that I I can't I can sit valid like I do
consider the non-aggression principle
fundamentally like valid as a concern
but even men artists will acknowledge
that it's not you know universally
applicable like you men are castes who I
assume you know reason is of course not
a anarcho-capitalist ik outlet accept
the moral validity or at least the
necessity of government as a compromise
and so you have to understand that
although taxation is theft which is
something that even Ben Shapiro exams
it's a necessary form of that and that's
going to be you know enduring the
problematic to anarcho-capitalists and
life people who apply that lens
absolutely but once I had begun to
understand the necessity of compromise I
began to stray from the idea that you
can just look toward a moral absolute
and like apply it universally and that
kind of begun the slow rolling process
where I'm where I evolved to become more
of a pragmatist by which I try to looks
at the specifics of details of
government action while retaining my my
my skepticism of government recognizing
that fundamentally is can be flawed
that's why you want to tailor government
toward specific issues and I realized
that there is more of a role in them
there's a a greater role for government
in places where I otherwise would not
have considered from that that Liberty
neighbors back yeah well yeah and I
think that reason is a pretty pragmatic
empirical version of Liberty or we a lot
of people put reason before it an
empirical pragmatic version of
libertarianism so I'm hoping you know if
you just if you just keep reading we'll
we'll pull you back a little bit I do
want to play I do want to play a clip
that will take us into the topic of the
future of the rights which I think that
you both you and Lex would consider
yourselves part of I'm gonna do that
Annoying libertarian thing where I say
that I'm neither left nor right so I'm
an impartial observer here but I do have
an interest in the future of the right
and the future of the left I want both
to be in a healthy place that does not
tear everything apart and I think that
you guys might represent one way forward
here so let's play this clip from video
called what Milo's criticism of Jordan
Peterson teaches us general constant
access to the Internet and the immediate
exchange of information has led many a
commentator to an illusion of
omniscience
although the younger among us have
always been overly self-confident
temporarily frozen in a state of a
smart-aleck until they mature it's a
problem that's been made worse by the
Ghanim culture of e ownage of which Milo
was once the poster boy well
right about is that Peterson does talk
about a single idea for long stretches
of time would he and other mediums like
Joe Rogan are doing is filling that
demand for long-form thought-provoking
and substance rich content the demand
for Milo sudden pwnage videos aren't
nearly as high as it once was when Milo
asked the question repeatedly if he's
the only one not getting Peterson's
appeal he clearly isn't but he's
certainly in the minority Milo's sheer
arrogance blinds him to why people would
care about long lectures which sometimes
entails metaphors about as he put it
bunnies or something well this isn't
good for Milo's declining public appeal
it is good for the health of a social
fabric instead of trotting out what are
now actual obvious isms like the gender
pay gap Peterson is teaching those same
young people how to approach ideas
seriously and with the humility of their
limitations although on one hand the
internet can induce that sort of
arrogance it has also opened the door
for those like Peterson and Weinstein to
publicly engage in high-level rigorously
scientific discourse beyond the value of
those conversations themselves they give
us a much-needed lesson into what mature
disagreement looks like very often we're
seeing the act of thinking without an
ulterior motive
while our biases are unavoidable these
conversations are about as near as we
can get to seeing the process of
thinking your way through ideas
unfiltered and without pretense where
it's a norm for conversations to be
weighed down by each side clinging to
their pre-existing answers like a
football these conversations and
lectures give us a rare and welcome
escape from those pretentious displays
so you're promoting the idea of
conversation and free discourse and
that's something as a libertarian I'm
totally on board with and I think that
is really the answer to get us out of
this weird moment that we are in right
now and you kind of single out Milo here
who has fallen by the wayside you don't
hear much about him anymore I believe
he's like millions of dollars in debt
now or something like that and he yeah
he really represented a certain moment
this was like the pre Trump like frenzy
and now he's being replaced by something
else but there are still like little
versions of Milo around that I've seen
you
is also criticized you've called up
people like Charlie Kirk people like
Tommy Lauren the so I'm curious what
your take is on the current state of the
right what are the the different
directions you think that it could go
and maybe what what direction would you
like to see it go the directions I mean
you can go in a couple of directions oh
okay I'm not sure what I can do about
that but and let me ask you one other
question first before you talk about the
different directions that it might go in
do you am i right that you are something
like a would be described something like
a conservatory inand Lexa's you know
more traditional conservative is that
about right I would say I would say that
we're having we fall away pretty much a
we fall away pretty similar trajectory
ideologically I I would say that you
know we kind of I think we kind of both
play devil's advocate a little bit all
the time where you know he'll offer the
more traditionalist perspective and then
I'll think of the more Pro change more
progressive the actual sense of the term
not progressive in terms of you know
whatever progressives in the ideology of
progressivism but I'll think of the more
you know dynamic order kind of thinking
I'll apply more of that lens to it and
he'll you know he'll respond likewise so
we kind of have that dialogue that's
continually occurring but in terms of
the and by the way the echo is fixed so
that's not an issue but from the but
from the standpoint of where where the
bright could go they can go in like two
directions and they're both explained
what is more enduring than the other one
is in the direction of populism in the
form of trumpism so to speak which we
can understand is probably not gonna
have a lot of sustainability as we're
seeing actually pretty recently which
Trump's sort of erratic decisions which
is fundamentally pissed off every
coalition on the right whether it be his
withdrawal from Syria we should pissed
off the pro interventionist
or it'd be is caving on the wall which
you know obviously pisses off is base
you can see that when it comes down to
governance specific things specific
decisions are weighed upon you and when
you're a populist it it's manin it's
kind of like a term without meaning it's
just it's just it refers to a sort of
undefined sense of like supporting the
people which is good during a campaign
which is good when you're striving
toward a undefined end but when you know
when when rubber meets the road and you
have to make those decisions they're
going to come down in one camp or
another and you're not going to be able
to appeal to every single member of your
base I feel like Abraham Lincoln's words
are pretty instructive here
where it concerns appealing you know
being able to please some of the people
some of the time but not all the people
all the time and that seems to me a sort
of fatal conceit conceit of the populace
that populace are fundamentally going to
encounter every each and every single
time they attempt to enact their agenda
which is why Europe which is much more
lent to populism than ideology in the
United States for reasons of its of its
of its origin it's a much more conflict
oriented society it's much more people
oriented and and that's why you I feel
like that's kind of why you see a lot of
the instability that you do today that's
compared to United States which has
proven much more sustainable and
resilient to populist you know fervor I
think that it can go in that direction
or and go into Peter Sohn Ian sort of
direction which is preserving the values
the values of the Western environment of
course the alignment has you know
Nicolas be points out is a number of
things but the Enlightenment of which
you know I speaking previously the
European enlightenment so to speak is
much very much different than the
American in life and I feel like that's
kind of what Jordan Peterson is a
representative representative on I feel
like he's much more representative of
that American Enlightenment which seeks
to preserve the the fundamental
teachings of of the West and and that's
what's what's kind of staved those
European that turbulence of Europe away
and you know Trump is you know I
worrying
shift in the european direction and i
would like to not see an fool i don't
want to see us become like a european
right like a you know a greek you know
Golden Dawn something like this alright
or a marine lepen I want to see the
American right remain a fixture like I
mean that's where Buckley even if
libertarians have the misgivings of
Buckley I mean he fundamentally is
somebody he was important he formed that
coalition the the you know three big
stool the of rye coalition that we see
today mm-hm and I would like to see it
continue to like there to be an ongoing
dialogue between libertarians and
conservatives mm-hmm and and so-called
neo-cons with a view which can't happen
but which is you don't really see a
parallel with in Europe you don't really
see that happening and I want to see
that continue to happen here and that's
where I would like to yeah I think the
part the leg of that stool where it all
breaks down is the militarism and we're
seeing that play out right now because
Trump is actually withdrawing troops
from Syria and possibly Afghanistan and
most of the libertarians I see out there
are basically cheering this and the
Conservatives are getting nervous do you
have any thoughts on if that can be
reconciled the the big foreign policy
disagreement that I think is really at
the heart in many ways of the
libertarian conservative divide yeah I
mean I see that I see myself as being
kind of in the middle of that because
I've had thoughts that are favorable to
both sides of that of that disagreement
which are in one hand I have an
appreciation for the uniqueness of
America abroad and because the fact
because of the differences
America has with Europe I have kind of
seen the necessity of our almost needing
to play parental role with regard to
them to preserve that World Order and I
understand the more interventionist
perspective to use that you know
pejorative term to describe it I
understand
where's that uh pejorative I didn't even
realize I thought that was just
descriptive energy interventions as
pretty is a little bit pejorative it is
what would you prefer to be called I
realist
well Rand Paul calls himself a realist
and yeah I embrace who thinks of
Rampal's with Rosa foreign-policy okay
that's a decent you know representation
okay so this is a realism is more or
less I've got a way oversimplified here
but interview Europe you're open to the
idea of intervention but it's when
there's a clear national interest and
that has to be very strictly defined
it's not just vaguely we're going to
create democracy in the Middle East it's
like this is a real what's that right
that used to be true position exactly I
used to be yeah Trump would say the same
thing and he was somebody who would pay
lip service the necessity of Congress
doing this and Mike Mike respected where
I come where I come down on us is
fundamentally that we all understand
that Congress has been in power part to
wage war and Dave shirk this for far too
long and my thinking is that if they
want a war in Syria they have to justify
it through debate and I'm not saying
that a intervention in Syria is
inherently unjustifiable in fact I don't
have enough information to come down on
that one way or the other cuz I don't I
simply don't know the extent to which
Isis is still active I'm sure Trump is
privy to information that none of us are
and I don't know how crucial this is to
American interests but that's something
for Congress to openly consider you know
with with full transparency
can't you take ownership up yeah for one
man to own this for better or for worse
like you know if the president decides
intervene is successful then he gets all
the credit or if it fails and his
administration and by extension his
party takes all the blame for it this is
childish this is cartoonish the way it
should work is that the Congress should
make the determination and whatever the
outcome is they take ownership for it
but of course they don't it's a huge
body and it's much easier to just you
know outsource that to a single figure
yeah and therefore they're free of it
yeah and I think yeah I think that sort
of procedural argument you know
following the what's laid out in the
Constitution and and making Congress
actually responsible is a way that
conservatives and libertarians could
come together if there are enough
conservatives that wake up to that I
haven't seen many really pushing for
that yet but hopefully
we'll we'll see some push in that
direction I think I did have seen
articles in National Review and so forth
are making arguments all along those
lines so that there might be some seeds
sprouting there
I want to go there's another question
here that I think will bring us back to
our what we were originally talking
about
it's from Jacob Stillman who says
there's been a rising demand for quick
paced interviews at leftist protests on
YouTube but the interviewers tend to
frame the answers of the marchers in a
comedic light through editing and loaded
questions are potentially biased
interviewers justified in spreading
political derision for internet
popularity if so why aren't they
regarded with similar criticism that you
give late-night show hosts in their
political diatribes so I think this kind
of brings us back to the Milo charlie
kirk type of characters who are just
basically all about owning the libs what
is your take on lib ownage well I would
say for one thing that when these when
they do this I mean look I mean you see
the same thing you do see the the the in
overlap between the people who do this
the difference being of course one is
the main one is mainstream the other is
not but they're at least transparently
partisan like you know that people like
I mean obviously you know somebody who
does this
the most prominent right we figure maybe
who does this is maybe flag his cause
you know what perspective he's coming
from he's going on like you know see our
TV and Fox News talking to Tucker
Carlson talking to Gavin McInnes you
know where he comes down on issues and
everybody intuitively understands this
to somebody like Jimmy Fallon Jimmy
Kimmel Jimmy Fallon's actually been
favored but Jimmy Kimmel and and others
but they kind of they are broadcast by
major television networks you know you
you they try to occupy a realm of kind
of like indifference that now that veil
has been lifted a little bit but when
that was the case they would feign a
different kind of plausible deniability
that I don't think something's like flex
talks or these these smaller youtubers
actually
which is why I don't really grade them
in the same way but I would also say
that going to protests in exposing the
absurdity of them it's kind of almost
not even necessarily a partisan thing
which is maybe counterintuitive because
the fact that these protests are just
like utterly you know asinine oftentimes
I don't even think oftentimes they're
all that edited because we've done a
video of that description and we cut out
a number of sections but they were it
wasn't because they were really quality
or that they were really well informed
as to why they were protesting it was a
women's March protesters it was just
that they were gathered there to express
their like unanimous outrage for reasons
that you don't need themselves don't
fully understand and it's it's not quite
the same thing as someone like say Jon
Stewart clipping up you know out of
context statements from politicians
otherwise maybe you are knowledgeable
but taken out of context and making them
seem ridiculous to gain political points
I don't necessarily think going to
protest it's the same exact thing is
that it's just it's pure spectacle I
don't know if it degrades conversation
but you know it's just that every every
side has their lowest common denominator
and I think that I think that the larger
ones do something a little bit more
pernicious than that you and you you are
more than willing to criticize your own
side and even people that you agree with
you've mentioned ben shapiro a couple
times you seem to have an admiration for
him but you have criticized his take on
rap for instance and that's a another
thing that i like about your channel is
anyone who's willing to criticize the
road side first of all worth listening
to because they're being honest secondly
you want to engage with pop culture
instead of sneer at it and that's a big
problem that i have with a lot of
conservatives in general is they look at
a lot of pop culture is just that it's
this low degraded thing that only exists
to be criticized and the i thought your
kind of ode to rap here was
pretty interesting and I want to give
people a little look at that real quick
at that rap is not nearly as thoughtless
or decadent as its critics believe by
focusing solely on the excesses of rap
they miss a key part of raps role in the
culture although it has its elements
like Kendrick Lamar who seek to
outsource blame to the police or white
people for their conditions there's a
much more potent strain that celebrates
south determination and grit where
virtually every other industry of
mainstream entertainment and media has
cloaked itself in contempt for our
capitalist system the overwhelming
majority of rappers celebrate their
hard-won successes in doing so they
offer a message of inspiration to those
who otherwise would only hear that the
lack of success is because they're being
denied something by an oppressive other
this is the only cultural force it
serves as a rare voice of optimism in an
increasingly pessimistic world all right
first of all it's just marvel at those
graphics again and the music which I
believe Lex actually composes a lot of
the original music - is that right yeah
yeah and so yeah what kind of made the
point there about what is valuable about
rap but do you get that sense what I was
talking about before do you agree that
there needs to be a more kind of serious
grapple engagement with pop culture from
the right yeah I mean that's the only
way it's actually going to succeed right
we can't just pretend that we you know
live on an island and we're going to be
able to push against the flow or maybe
to borrow you know Buckley's words
standeth word history and yell stop and
that it's not going to run us over we do
have to acknowledge that there are
trends that exist and instead of pushing
against that current we should attempt
to like understand it for one thing and
to appreciate why people are sympathetic
to it and fundamentally if enough people
follow something I believe fun I sort I
come to the sorting point that a people
enough people are following one thing
you have to at the very least understand
and sympathize with why they're going in
that direction because they
probably do have legitimate reason
reasons and for the reason that you know
rap for for example has become the most
listening to John room music I don't
think that's you know an accident I
don't think that is something that just
sprung out of the other for no
explanation and or effort has been to
explain why that is and in fact that
there are glimmerings of conservative
thought or you know
well conservative thought fine mentally
within that that can be that can be
salvaged and mind and channel that that
maybe a lot of conservatives don't
appreciate it like ben shapiro who
thinks that you know it's just it's just
not going to be and they also have to be
realistic that's where the pragmatist
within me comes in where somebody like
Shapiro is like oh I just listen to
classical music and maybe some little
rock sympathetically some rock and it's
like well that that ship is sail that's
not where we're going so either get on
board or you're going to be left behind
mm-hmm and you know if you if you if you
don't join a movement it's just going to
leave you and you're not going to have
any say in it you're not gonna have any
influence and the purpose is to actually
build it toward your advantage that's
that's more standpoint
yeah and and it's us it's good it's like
you shouldn't approach it from the from
the perspective that you know it's it's
to be taken literally or that it people
are being seduced by it
finest news my messages and degeneracy
it's like okay that's great but you know
for the same thing it's just like people
had we people have had concerns about
different manifestations of art
throughout history I don't even need to
cite all the different manifestations of
it but you know people have been
resistant toward artistic change the
dawn of time because they think it's
gonna cause this social or that social
ill it's just like well I mean it's mass
violence ensuing because of rap well I
mean certainly not I mean if you you
know know anything about like say
Stephen Peters work you know that we're
moving the opposite direction so you
know you might you might have different
cultural concerns but the response to
that is not to ignore them but to
address them right and we we've talked a
lot about some of your criticisms of the
right and I want to talk about a little
bit more in a second about what
direction you think we should be
you mentioned Jordan Peterson as one
example I want to get your explanation
of what you think Jordan Peterson brings
to the table and why so many people are
responding positively to him but first I
want to just take a detour and talk
about the future of the left and one
possible route there is America's
favorite young socialist Alexandria okgo
Cortez and you all first of all the
response from the right and some
libertarians to miss Cortez cacio Cortez
has been a little disappointing I think
there's been this rush to dunk on her
and she has some merrily rejected those
dunks like to Kambei matumbo make a
horrible 1990s but you all I think may
put forward a model of the right
direction to go with criticizing her
which is to you know actually engage
with the ideas she's promoting she is a
part of the or I don't know if she still
is but she was the time she got elected
part of the democratic socialists of
America which has an interesting
platform that you delved into and I'm
going to play a little bit of your video
which is called Alexander Ocasio Cortez
rethink this the unbridled power of
transnational corporations underwritten
by the major capitalist nations has
created a world economy where the wealth
and power of a few was coupled with
insecurity and downward mobility for the
vast majority of working people in the
time it took the democratic socialists
to discuss and write this statement and
then post it on the Internet the
unbridled power of transnational
corporations underwritten by the major
capitalist nations have reduced the
number of people living on one dollar 90
cents a day by 19 percent
and since 1999 the amount of people
living on less than one dollar ninety
cents a day is declined by a further 62
percent meaning that the amount of
people below the global poverty line has
fallen by more than two
since 1990 in real terms that's over a
billion human beings saved from abject
poverty in the span of two decades and
probably the biggest human miracle of
our lifetimes if not world history it
should be clear that Democratic
socialists would like to halt this
global capitalist achievement and the
service of moral masturbation the
problem with Alexandra Acacio Cortez the
Democratic socialists of America is that
they seek to design grand social and
economic changes while under the
influence of the worst drug of them all
hubris in such a state of arrogance they
brush aside the past failures of
socialism like there's nothing to be
learned from the mistakes of their
ideological ancestors or even worse like
they're smarter than them or impervious
to the same kinds of corruption and
incompetence that slowly converted the
ideal of a workers utopia into an
Orwellian hellscape okay your your
audience is an audience that's willing
to sit and listen to a thoughtful
20-minute video essay but the reality is
we live in Twitter world and Facebook
world where it's all about dueling memes
so how do we get I mean how do you think
that we get it into people's head that
socialism does not work it's different
from social democracy which is the
much-vaunted
what the much-vaunted nordic countries
have going on with a generous welfare
state but still market economies and
that this throughout history has never
ended well can you think of any
strategies there it's you have to
undercut the assumption that people have
the the tendency a lot of people were
sympathetic Oh socialism the dependency
on their part to say well shouldn't
people shouldn't evil they ask the
question shouldn't they have this like
ideally shouldn't we have this and it's
almost like you know the playing the
role of a parent who explains that
although yes ideally in a perfect world
in the absence of scarcity we should
have these things every
one should have access to health care
everyone should have access to these
things my common line of reasoning has
been okay so what you mean SS cities are
not public rights where does that end so
healthcare seems intuitively because a
lot of these things seem intuitively
desirable to people and intuitively
mandatory almost you kind of have to ask
them okay so should we mandate that food
is a universal right should we mandate
that water is a universal right and what
are the long-term consequences to that
and I find that when you break those the
logical conclusions to them down they
tend to like you know either either they
agree or they go yeah okay I mean I see
how this isn't really tenable and you
have to explain the problem scarcity to
them which is something that Thomas all
did very well in basic economics which
like if anything in in a in a rational
world would actually be a mandatory
reading he explains to the forefront you
know and essentially he says that you
know scarcity is a thing I mean kind of
defines economics essentially on that on
that on that basis and you what what
what is necessary is that you explain to
them how prices work and why they exist
and it's just that we've done a very
piss-poor job of this place explaining
the fact that we live in a reality of
scarcity and I think that people have
unfortunately forgotten that scarcity is
a is an existent reality because of our
prosperity I always look at capitalism
as a sort of like fishbowl where you're
ensconced in so much water which is
prosperity and to the point that you
don't realize that you're surrounded by
water and you know of course that
doesn't negate the fact that you
encounter struggle but you don't realize
how the depth to which that's trouble
can go yeah and you can't you you kind
of have to remind people with that and
right and so in that in that analogy
then the if the water is getting a
little murky then the Socialists come in
and say we're gonna you know take care
of this water and make sure everyone has
clean water I mean
while they're draining the entire bowl
and then it's all over right yeah yeah
the problem fundamentally is that the
water will never be clear because that
will always be a reality right
functionally the scarcity has been
mitigated to the extent it's constantly
being reduced and reduced but you know
even even the Utopia is always on the
horizon it's it's not going to be a
permanent state of reality no matter
what there's even once material scarcity
is eliminated and that's where I find so
much value and thinkers like Dostoevsky
and obviously Peterson was answering
that other problem which is that where
functional scarcity material scarcity
has become a almost non non-issue in the
Western world there is that that greater
problem where which kind of you know had
diverted to that subject to deviate a
little bit from course I found just the
sort of rationalism of libertarianism
kind of unfulfilled and that's what
conservatives were hoping to answer a
little bit which is you know in the
absence of material scarcity because
obviously capitalism answers that
question best better than anything else
how do we how do we fulfill that other
than other incompleteness how do we
actually answer that and you know it the
big problem that is presented in the
wake of capitalism success is how do we
answer that and that's obviously the
problem with which Nietzsche is
fundamentally concerned which is
obviously which is something computers
and reiterates that although God is now
dead it's it doesn't end there
it's not in a it's not a statement of
exaltation it's a statement of almost
morning which is like okay in the wake
of God what do we produce to fill that
void like what do what man has to create
his own meaning now hmm now that God has
proven to be something that it's not
believable from an empirical standpoint
what we what do we what is your answer
to that at absence and unfortunate the
market has the answer to material
scarcity it doesn't have the answer to
the other kind of scarcity of the soul
essentially how do we answer that
problem and you know I'm so in search of
an answer and okay so that seems to be
what partially what explains the appeal
of Jordan Peterson is he is helping
people I mean he has a book called maps
of meaning so he's helping people you
know putting this guidebook out there to
find whatever the meaning in the
Nietzschean sense you know constructed
their own meaning and there we I
actually pulled a clip that you all made
of Jordan Peterson reading a poem by
Frederick Friedrich Nietzsche called a
tarantulas so that'll be a good way to
kick off this post of the conversation I
think and this is possibly the trickiest
of the 1791 videos that I've seen so far
and that's saying something behold this
is the whole of the tarantula do you
want to see the tarantula itself here
hangs its web that's it so that it
trembles there it comes willingly
welcome tarantula your triangle and
symbol sits black on your back and I
also know what sits in your soul
revenge sits in your soul wherever you
bite black scabs grow your poison makes
the soul whirl with revenge
thus I speak to you in a parable you who
make souls world you preachers of
equality to me you are tarantulas and
secretly vengeful but I shall bring you
secrets to light therefore I laugh in
your faces with my laughter of the
heights
therefore I tear at your webs that your
rage may lure you out of your lie hole
and your revenge may leap out from
behind your word justice for that man be
delivered from revenge that is for me
the bridge to the highest hope and a
rainbow after long storms the tarantulas
of course would have it otherwise what
justice means to us is precisely that
the world be filled with the storms of
our revenge
thus they speak to each other we shall
wreak vengeance and abuse on all who's
equals
or not let's do the tarantula hearts
about okay so give it to us why what do
you think explain I know everyone kind
of has their Jordan Peterson hot aook at
this point but what do you think
explains this phenomenon I would say
what Nietzsche's fundamental point there
was that many of the people many of the
people who preach the preach the virtues
of equality or not motivated they
pretend to be motivated by virtue by by
the desire to by the desire to how would
I put it
they they they appreciate in terms of
the desire to what I say we formulate
that thought right quick
I would say that they preach it in terms
of they'd be okay so they they formulate
it such that they think equality is
blanking hmm well let's take it in a
slightly different direction which is
why do you think that Jordan Peterson is
resonating with so many people and if
the right we're going to go in a Peter
Sounion type direction as it seems like
you would like to see what might that
look like it would look like an
appreciation for values and I mean
appreciation is kind of the central term
there and that's fundamentally what the
that that entire epigraph that entire
segment is is is something about which
is it's it's motivated by resentment
rather than appreciation for what what
has had and so they the trash Allah so
to speak they are the they preached
equality on one hand and they claim that
the quality is going to fulfill that
that that that dissatisfaction but in
fact they actually my brain is not
working right now
I think that one I think that for me
what Peterson is doing is he's he's
bringing religion into he recognizes the
power of myth
obviously he's an expert in myth and he
I mean myth is what kind of bound humans
together it's like a defining feature of
our species but now we are in this
rational world and we're in a place
where we understand evolution for
instance and he is it seems like his
project is to integrate that and so
we're going to be doing tomorrow we're
going to be talking about our
post-modernism video and this is a space
where Peterson is he's been harsh very
critical of the idea of post-modernism
because we had modernism which came out
of the Enlightenment which was all about
categorization and all about you know
applying the scientific method to
everything including society itself and
then the postmoderns kind of in a broad
sense questioned all of that and said
well ye you the limits of you applying
this there are limits to you applying
this rationalism to complex systems and
that is the sort of where it's sort of
intersects with what libertarians and
especially the followers Hayekian type
libertarians are questioning the ability
of for instance the states to manage
something like the economy quote unquote
rationally and Peterson is interesting
and sometimes perplexing figure to me
because he seems to be kind of trying to
he's a critic of post-modernism because
he
thinks there has to be some sort of base
there but he's also a little bit coy
about like are we supposed to literally
believe in these myths or these
religions and so that's what I'm
wondering how that integrates into
conservatism because right there's a
sort of I mean there's a he's he's a
scientist and he believes in evolution
and that's always been a little bit of a
sticking point for the right so where do
you think all that is is going the
social conservatives like to guide the
conservative perspective where concerns
evolution toward that toward that favor
and I think that he is somebody who the
reason that he's kind of quite with
regard to whether or not we should apply
evolutionary sorry to apply biblical
teachings literally or to apply a
literal belief in God is simply because
the fact that maybe he doesn't fully
know and this is something he's kind of
clear on when you listen to him speak
for any length of time he will well say
will admit of his freely that he doesn't
know because of the fact that a number
of inexplicable phenomena occur and of
course that's an argument from ignorance
is not an argument unto itself it's not
just that like we don't understand
everything so therefore God exists and I
wouldn't say that's the argument he's
making but I would say that he is saying
that we we don't know that this is the
case and that some things or so
unbelievable as to merit at least the
consideration and I think that what he's
mostly saying is that there is so much
truth to be found within the Bible and
of course there were all the
contradictions that somebody like Sam
Harris would point out that is the
continuing difference there they did the
friction between rationalism belief that
will like kind of always exist but there
is enough there that can maybe be
reconciled with
evolutionary psychology which is what
his biblical lectures really are they're
the effort to assess the Bible from an
evolutionary psychological perspective
to almost lend it justification to kind
of answer the dgn question of how we you
know find how we construct our own moral
sort of center in the absence of God or
maybe we can rediscover God
maybe we can deepen our understanding of
what God supposedly is through a
different lens
maybe the lens was wrong maybe we have
to fix that maybe we have to correct
that and you know I mean that's kind of
how I interpret Peterson's approach to
to the Bible and and to religious
thoughts you know and you know of course
you can you can find that in other
traditions and Eastern traditions it is
a lot of people to point it out but you
know what we in the West
mostly understand is the Bible and the
which which has kind of the moral
foundation that we built or a society on
that's that's really a and it's it's we
should not toss the baby out with the
bathwater and you know operate from
ignorance and assume that we that
there's nothing of value there because
once we do that we're gonna find
ourselves in in some unpredictable
circumstances we don't know what unfolds
from that because this is the secular
this movement of secularism is very new
like it's a recent phenomenon in Europe
is over 50 percent it religious it's
it's something that's quite new
secularism is obviously the u.s. is less
secular but there is even among American
Christians an unspoken kind of
skepticism religion like people will
identify as there being something out
there or maybe they believe in God but
they don't actually and I don't think
that was that's always probably been the
case but I don't I think that's a more
recent thing and we have to be kind of
have to figure that out collectively we
we've lost that fixture that navigation
tool and so at the very least even if
that's not true how do we take from that
and apply it to the otherwise
in chaotic discipline of empiricism
because obviously science is constantly
changing
we don't know maybe 50 years from now it
was something class B rightfully pointed
out as a feature of post-modernism how
do we know if something that is true
scientifically is going to be true
scientifically in the next 50 years
right only something like God however
you come to define it is permanent only
something like God is something that we
can understand across generations and
it's the only thing that gives us
meaning over the course of that extended
period of time and then you have to ask
the question further how do you form a
society on the basis of something like
science or a scientist that is
constantly changing how do you actually
like how do you ground yourself in the
face of that constant change and that's
something that like with climbing mental
illness issues of mental illness how do
we navigate that right like there's
there's that that that's where the flaw
comes in and I hate yeah yeah and there
there's there's a question that jumped
out of me on this topic from bear arms
who said do you think the right will
ever support the blurring of gender
lines under the expectation it will lead
to a more flexible economy and the
reason I bring that in it seems a little
off the wall but it's that that's where
I get a little bit ambivalent about
Peterson is that you know FA Hyack wrote
a famous essay called why I am NOT a
conservative and Hayek was a great he
was an advocate he was very Burkean in a
sense that he said we need to pay
attention to tradition and discard it at
our own risk in peril because things
emerged this is a merchant order they
emerged for reasons we can't quite
explain always or don't and so you know
you're treading in dangerous waters if
if you just discard tradition on the
other hand he's not a conservative
because the government should never be
you know criminalizing deviant behavior
and even
society kind of being overly oppressive
towards people that are living outside
the norm can be dangerous because these
are the innovators and so I sometimes I
hear Peterson saying like you need to
kind of strike this balance and walk
that line and it's very Hayek in in a
way and that's kind of the way I see
things but I worry that there's a sort
of clinging to some rigid categories
that are not necessarily going to be
valid in the future so what do you think
I would say that you have to ask the
question of why people are pop almost
frenziedly clinging to those to those
fixtures in the face of like
unprecedented technological and social
change things that are that that that
would have been unspeakable even a few
decades ago or now and they weren't just
unspeakable like a few centuries ago
they were unspeakable for the entirety
of our country's history and beyond like
you know gay marriage like you know the
demographic shift that's occurring and
it's causing all kinds of reactions it's
causing all kinds of people it's cause
it's causing people to kind of just be
flabbergasted in the wake of it because
it's happening so quickly and that's
simply because of how rapidly it is that
sorry to take a little bit how how my
cough disrupted my thinking process but
it's causing us to question the
reliability of these institutions and
that's where I'm fundamentally concerned
because of how rapidly technological and
demographic change is occurring and it's
being facilitated by a signal to
technological change because of the fact
that you know the cellphone is such a
recent advent that this that all these
technologies rose in the last century
which is just like it does so I mean
what's the proposed solution to that
though is there some sort of government
intervention or is this like an
awareness thing that's where I'm getting
a little
that's exactly it yeah I mean that's the
problem where there are too many
libertarians were kind of you kind of
say well if you question these movements
are you proposing that the government is
to intervene and it's like well no I
don't believe that no I don't believe
that the government should be able to
abridge the First Amendment mm-hmm and I
of course I believe in free speech but
there's a more nuanced take to be had
there which is which is which is by John
Jonathan hi the the psychologist
Jonathan I am sure you're familiar with
them or many others he makes a
distinction between free speech and
viewpoint diversity and in a
conversation with Ezra Klein who took
care to talk about you know viewpoint
diversity rather than free speech and
too often those concepts are complaint
right where you when you say we have to
protect the free speech movement has to
protect speech on private platforms and
it's like well of course free speech is
only protected against government
intervention but the what but you have
to consider free speech is a principle
unto itself if you consider free speech
is something intrinsically valuable and
which which means the preservation of
the ability to speak your mind according
to your viewpoint and as for
perspectives because the fact that
technology now allows us which is only
something that happened last couple
decades allows us to reveal how diverse
in our perspectives on how maybe even
how less shared they are then maybe we
took them for granted to be and we have
to become more tolerant of that we have
to be able to you know to use a language
that our generation so much likes we
have to learn how to become more
tolerant the fact that we actually do
have different viewpoints yeah and that
free speech is a way to expand the free
speech not in terms of govern protection
but in terms of like a sociological the
only thing that's going to the only
thing that's actually sustainable or
social differences are social solutions
so obviously government is a terrible
mediator for this every time the
government attempts to orchestrate
social change there's a it provokes a
reaction from free people as it should
because you're being told you're not
being persuaded of something that's the
nature of government it is for us so
you're not being persuaded of something
in response to that you're going to
resist it even if maybe you would be
sympathetic to the point of view yeah
government is so yeah you're I mean
you're you're you're saying that you
know it's it's the solution to this is
open honest dialogue and that is being
inhibited by a lot many different forces
social ostracism tech platform shutting
down people with divergent viewpoints
and I agree with you there I think that
that is the solution is we have to have
a more open dialogue that and people
need to be a little more resilient and
not get it's quite so easily offended I
think that's that's really is the only
way out of this
there's and that kind of brings us full
circle in a way to the clip we opened
with and I think we can bring in our
final clip here which has to do with the
latest sargon of akkad controversy where
and I am a little I admit that I'm not
totally steeped in this but in you so
you can fill in any gaps but my
understanding is Sargon of Akkad who's a
big YouTube guy who believe is somewhere
on calls himself a classical liberal but
he's very anti-immigration made some
comments on a stream or on a video where
he was calling alt-right racists the
n-word and possibly doing this in some
sort of ironic way to like teach them a
lesson or something anyway him saying
the word was what got him kicked off the
platform is that about right yeah it was
just the mere utterance of the word
alone okay provoked based rounds
reaction to ban okay and patreon
ultimately claims that it was not just
that incident that provoked their
response and him it was instead that
who's a compounding phenomenon okay I
wish they they claimed that he there was
another incident at VidCon I think last
year maybe the year before that where he
was confronted by noted feminists in
need sarkeesian who accosted him like
she responded to him and she was doing a
talk he was she sitting there and she
attacked him and they claimed that I
don't know the particulars of that but I
know that he responded her I don't know
it's like in what context but he's
clearly not somebody who is motivated by
racial animus or misogyny or anything
like that but nevertheless they they're
seizing upon their like really reaching
for different explanations that would
justify this action because the backlash
has been some fears hmm and for them
they they are claiming right now that
context matters when they factor in
decisions 2d platform people right and
it goes beyond deep platforming it's
depriving people of financial security
it's depriving people of their means by
which to support themselves and I don't
think that I think that they have their
their fundamental flaw has been that
they miscalculated how severe the
response that would be right and they
don't under they don't appreciate that
it's not going to be something that just
blows over
yeah such such as it might with you know
YouTube or Facebook or Twitter hmm that
they actually control the means by which
people facilitate their survival and
they don't understand this is about
their their income this is about their
livelihoods yeah and they don't
understand that people are going to take
that very seriously and they don't think
that people understand that creators
aren't just you know individual
customers or clients they are people
with who having large base of support
often times and the people it's a matter
of voluntary exchange right well they
don't want to there's customers as they
are the the creators themselves their
customers the page the patrons yeah want
to give them their money in exchange for
the value theory turn to them and
there's this mill man who's saying
actually no and then they don't
understand that you know that's going to
cause a wave of consequences because of
the fact that they've responded in such
a arbitrary fashion well let me let me
play just a clip from your video on this
incident and then we'll come back and I
want to talk to you about what you're
planning to do as
independent creator to survive in this
environment
CEO of the world's largest tech company
declares that thought centers are no
longer allowed on their platforms that
announcement can probably be seen as a
pre lead to a broader effort to double
down on what has been underway since the
various YouTube Twitter and patreon
bannings many questions have been raised
as to how independent these tech giants
really are given how frequently their
moves to censor prominent right-wing
figures happen at the same time the
latest and probably least offensive
figure to be taken out by the Silicon
Valley led movement is youtuber sargon
of akkad whose patreon was wiped without
warning or notice he's someone who
identifies as a center-left classical
liberal became to prominence for his
takedowns of feminism and other strains
of identity politics those points of
view supposedly weren't what took him
out rather his having called alt writers
the n-word in an obscure live stream
watching Tim Cook outlined the kind of
basic morality he expects big tech to
adopt it gives us some insight as to
what would motivate such a harsh and
swift action he exasperatedly scolds
that if we can accept this morality we
have big problems it's a morality that
he apparently believes is totally
unambiguous if patreon is using the Tim
Cook standard of morality there is
totally no moral gray area behind
calling the outright in words the
context and intention and how a word is
used is a basically recognized factor in
any moral analysis any good faith trust
and verify censorship and for sure would
have seen as much the basic morality
unelected platform cop Tim Cook
describes patently isn't so basic as it
turns out since calling racists the
racist terms they use is meant to be a
moral crime and you they bring up in
that video that the fact that back to
the Alex Jones D platforming that we
talked about the beginning these
platforms all acted in concert and the
same day well I mean we don't know that
they actually communicated with each
other but it's pretty easy to assume
that they did considering it all
happened at once or maybe it was just
this kind of cascade where no one wanted
to be the last person holding the Alex
Jones hot potato but what worries me
about that is first of all that
perceived coordination and then secondly
there is a connection to the government
here because they've all the tech people
all the tech CEOs have been dragged in
front of Congress and grilled and
there's been rumblings about taking away
section 230 which protects these
platforms from third-party liability
from being sued for content that appears
on their platform and so there's this
implicit threat happening from the
government that I think is affecting
their behavior and it was telling that
jack of twitter was the one only person
who kind of took a free-speech stand
with alex jones and then like the day
after he testified before congress
kicked them off so there's something
that seems like there's stuff going on
behind the scenes there that is is
definitely concerning what are you
planning to do about it as an
independent content creator what I would
say on that note is first and foremost
that it's almost like we don't have to
speculate to a certain extent
that lot of these things are coordinated
because in you know jack conte was more
or less asked about this directly in his
interview with dave rubin and he said
that yeah we do communicate very
frequently about all sorts of things and
we communicate very often and that was
kind of the parallel that we were
drawing which is that it's it's it's
very eerie that you know he would say
this kind of brusque line with someone
like the Aruban and then you know that
this there comes this almost anti
freethought sermon given by Tim Cook
which is that we are to believe well
it's a sin to facilitate these people on
our platforms and maybe it's just an
optical coincidence and unfortunate one
at that mm-hmm but you can see how would
lead to that that perception sure and
then of course there are these these
other concerns and maybe the companies
are concern that the government is going
to you know hold them accountable for
what people do on their on their
networks I'd hold them responsible as
publishers but we also understand that
that
from frankly the the left this comes
from the 2016 election which is the
belief that Trump won because of Russian
intervention right like the fake news is
a definite pretence for this yes and
that and that could be another
unfortunate consequence of the Trump
presidency by which once the Democrats
regain power they're going to seize upon
this claim this unfounded claim this as
of yet yeah what evidence claim because
we have so many other reasons to believe
that Trump was elected so many more
plausible reasons that were that Trump
is elected for better or for worse then
the fact that Russians put out a few
boomer husk memes that were like Pro
Trump right you know it's farcical but
enough people believe it in government
or at least they pretend to believe it
in them
then maybe they'll act upon it yeah and
of course they have not been able to
because only recently they gained
control the house but of course not
gonna move on to it until unless and
until they gain control of the Senate
and then even then until they gain
control of both the Senate and the house
and you know enough seats that they
would survive a GOP presidential veto so
they have to have all those you know
cards aligned such that they could they
could meet meaningfully right exercise
something so mad so so on such a massive
scale yeah but you think they'll seize
that opportunity if they get it look I
mean I think the political will is there
yeah I think that there were enough
people who think that the Russian stole
the election that they could plausibly
if they gate enough control of
government they think they would mean
they would they would try to implement
right because a Russian posts accounted
for like point one percent of all
political posts or some something along
those lines so yeah huge huge problem
and so what she what is your contingency
plan are you gonna seize an antenna and
start a pirate radio station if it all
goes down or what yeah back up hostage
yeah we're just go in there I mean
that's something that only happened a
libertarian society unfortunately there
very nice but yeah ultimately what the
way the way it has to works that
creators have to they have to kind of
undercut that that that that middleman
because the future is definitely
uncertain with regard to the internet
we're still in the wild Western days of
this this grand project and what we have
to do because of that is cut out the
middleman and start our own websites
start our own means of transfer and it
has to be on decentralized servers as
well so that's gonna be part of that
future right yeah yeah exactly
and he goes not saying to to get full
libertarian some of that answer is found
a little bit in crypto yes the fact that
banks or is part of this problem because
I mean in in some bail terms patreon
that themselves have said that they have
to take into consideration yeah the
broader world of the broader monetary
world essentially yeah that's the choke
point we saw it all the way going all
the way back to when they first choked
off WikiLeaks that's where it all
started
and you know there is a there was a
literal government program called
operation choke point where they were
cutting off unsavory businesses through
the banking system so I think I think
you're right and I we are gonna have to
wrap up soon but I want to kind of
finish off with this last question that
came via email from Brian what do you
personally find to be the most
interesting thing going on in American
politics right now and are there any
topics you'd like to cover in the near
future so maybe this can be our our
final thought here is what is next for
1791 so I would say the most interesting
thing but the problems that we are going
to have to confront which are the rise
of automation this is this is the
problem that we're beginning to see
bubble on the surface and I think that
was best represented by Tucker cross in
his conversation with ben shapiro which
is that there was going to be a process
of mass automation and thus the mass
displacement of say even the the largest
employer in America which is the
trucking industry across every state and
not trucking industry but the driving
industry and that's the largest basis of
employment for people in this country we
have to see how the market integrates
that change how it responds to that and
we have to see how well we're gonna have
to see how we handle the massive
demographic change it was occurring as
well and such a rapid pace and you have
to see how those things are handled and
I think that's pretty much what is at
the forefront of people's minds today
and you know it's it's it's uncertain
but that's that's pretty much the those
are the the largest problems that we're
gonna have to face down really yeah I
think that maybe we're probably going to
be talking about those things pretty
heavily in the future great well I'm
looking forward to it you guys are doing
great work and I'm a fan that's why I
brought you on and want to thank
everyone also in the chat who asked
questions and also we're just having a
good conversation down there
everyone who emailed questions again the
channel is youtube-dot-com forward-slash
1791 l but they drop the L you have to
dig into their archives to find out why
I'm not going to go into it here and are
gonna be back tomorrow at 1:30 p.m. with
Nick Gillespie and mr. skeptic Michael
Shermer he's skeptical of everything
including post-modernism so they're
gonna wrangle about that they're going
to talk about the intellectual dark web
which we touched on today and they're
gonna talk about rationalism and
whatever else they feel like talking
about so if you have questions for
Michael or Nick you can email them let
me put up the email here actually
questions at reason.com
go ahead and send them there and we'll
see you back here tomorrow if you want
notifications remember too
subscribe and press the little
notification bell and thanks again we'll
see you tomorrow